[Music]
please apologize
[Music]
i don't want to wait
for the show to be over
i want to know
i don't want to wait for the show
[Music]
can't believe it
yeah
can you believe jack has aids
yes
god yes
he has sex with like every guy
all the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
food
changes
[Music]
um
that's the sound of the show being back
if i know many of you are here because
of the change my mind this is your first
time watching the daily show uh
sorry so
no we're not that's delicious it's some
homemade chai tea and just those words
left in my mouth i wanted to kick my own
ass well you should yeah but it's
delicious and apparently it's good for
you yeah would you like me to slap you
uh well we'll get into that hey that's
my question of the day you get right off
the bat if you're here from change my
mind i know we have some new folks
who've sort of funneled in when is it so
comment below that's what helps with the
youtube algorithm and they don't like us
and a lot of your comments don't show up
too so we'll talk about that tomorrow
but uh when is it okay to slap a
person
when is it okay to slap a person is it
an offensive joke do you only slap
someone
as a return slap for violence or are
there words that at some point you know
are there actual other fighting words
these are terms that we used to use uh
spoiler alert i don't think that a joke
about uh someone who chooses to shave
their head
i don't think them's fighting words but
that's just you we'll talk about that
we'll talk about the florida don't say
gay bail which is not an actual bill and
it doesn't say anything about don't
saying gay also ron perlman is the only
person who uses reverse prosthetics
and uh we have ben shapiro on the show
oh nice so and he's you know a lot of
people tried to slap him so we have him
on the show a little bit later but
before any of that look let me just tell
you if we don't tell you that we're not
doing a show here okay if you missed the
show you're saying hey they didn't
announce it it mean we're doing it every
day monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern that's just when you tune in
notifications don't always work
subscriptions don't always work so tune
in 10 a.m eastern or you can go to
rumble or mug club if it's not here on
youtube it is still streaming live
live without a net
like chris o'donnell's parents in that
uh oh batman and robin
so sad so sad your parents weren't
killed by a by a psychopath yes they
were all right
gerald a how are you sir i am doing
better than will smith how are you
i don't know if you're doing better than
will smith i think i am i mean i don't
have an oscar but he doesn't seem to be
all that too remorseful well my wife is
also not beating me into submission well
your wife's also not sleeping with other
men ah yeah that too it really is the
foundation
it's you know what i would say it's a
it's not necessarily the foundation but
it is a non-negotiable yeah
yeah yeah it's almost one of the primary
tenets of marriage no monogamy
yes
after when you turn the cheating into an
open relationship because there's so
much of it yeah you're like no no no
this is retroactive open relationship i
wonder if will smith hired a private
detective yeah to figure out if his wife
was cheating on him and he just walked
out in the balcony he's like yeah right
there they're
yeah they're having sex five seconds
later his name was dick privates yes
it's like i'm actually in line yes i'm
in line
i was just waiting in the den when you
called me didn't you hear my phone ring
it was on vibrate i could hear it from
the yeah she requests that
all right you hear him you love him you
can follow him at uh landow dave on
twitter dave landau how are you sir ahoy
i'm good good complain good all right
that's it well you know what we're going
to change that because uh before we get
to will smith slapping and obviously
dave and i being on on tour and doing
stand-up uh have a lot of opinions about
comedians uh it being open season on
comedians and i've had to deal with
people trying to slap me and kill me for
a long time i'm on the isis kill list
and i have uh trans amoebas trying to
slap me so it's just wow yeah is there
like a reward can i collect
well you can collect uh you can collect
a slap in return no are you a trans
amoeba is that what you're getting at
yeah you're getting that the trans
amoeba doesn't have rewards dave it's
the isis trickly gerald yeah have you
been to the trans uh amoeba gas station
yeah
they're getting the trans-atlantic slap
fest
that was weak the trans-siberian slap
you're weak social genitalia yes that's
not fair i really shouldn't make fun of
comedians no it's not it's not it's not
nice that's not nice that being said
your wife is a saint thank you unlike
jada pinkett who's just an absolute just
she's just a rat now she's the patriot
saint of spreading yes
what you meant to say the patriots saint
of eagles that's what i talked about
it's meant you said spreading you you
could spread eagle you made it okay so
first it's a bird yes a powerful bird
it's a bird it's a planet it's a [ __ ]
they're rare
she's able to bang 20-year-old rappers
in a single bound they're bald eagles
looser than a speeding fishnet okay now
uh kim jong-un last week announced you
know he had this new international con
continental ballistic missile icbm is
what we're going to call it don't
confuse with the computer company
and uh we showed you this uh kim jong-un
picture well a picture of him wearing a
sick leather jacket and now we have a
promo video
from north korea
to match everyone tremble and fear
[Music]
kill him yeah
that's where i got my 19th hole in one
he's like pluto blue charski his watch
is two hours off yeah
[Applause]
oh there's more
his arrows are pointing to snack time
[Laughter]
i like wrenchables what's
[Music]
that's enough weird that's enough leave
let's see
yes uh yes
we get the point yeah
keeps eating people's lunch i was gonna
say that's where all the peanut butter
pretzels went yeah all the time
i got to do another costco run my name's
on the bag
okay moving on from this this look
because we had two changed my minds go
up obviously this happened everyone's
talking about the chris rock slap but
there's more to it than just you know
chris rock was slapped by will smith who
never would have done it if it was
anyone other than if it was the rock
any other rock yeah any other rock if it
was an actual rock right yeah just
wouldn't have happened keep my wife's
name that's hard out it hurts
you know
so uh no we don't will so you know no we
don't why do people always say that so
we've been off for a couple of days but
uh there are some developments that have
taken place that i think are look this
is actually a really important moment
for society at large and it's an
important moment specifically for you
know entertainers for comedians for
anyone who actually uh speaks publicly
for a living and people who act as
though this is just some kind of a
disagreement or something that happened
at the oscars
you're missing the point so let me just
show you for those of you who missed it
uh will smith standing up for his um
i mean
wife jada i love you g.i jane two can't
wait to see it all right
he's laughing until he sees that she's
back on her face
and this is how you know they're in a
horrible way okay yes i'm out here oh
richard
[Laughter]
oh wow
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i james keep my wife's
name out your [ __ ]
that's because someone else's balls are
in hers yes oh
well that's what that's the moment you
were like oh this isn't staged yeah
right he's actually upset yeah
he's upset because that's pent up rage
from being embarrassed publicly by his
wife for so long so long that's really
the reality of the entire situation is
he has been humiliated by her and then
when she looked at him yeah he's a cuck
i mean i hate to say it like that's such
a cheap word to me that's the actual but
that's the actual terminology and now
he's getting up because he's ashamed
right he's scared of her oh yeah she's
mentally and she's mentally abusive who
knows physically but mentally abusive
yeah the second he sees the rage in her
he gets up and that's his reaction yeah
get out of your marriage will yeah
that's a horrible place you're in you're
a terror
i felt honestly i i love chris rock too
and he did nothing wrong at all i'm
gonna say that and will smith i think
that he's just broken right now because
of that woman yeah i think she needs to
get out and i don't think people should
be piling on them the way that they are
yeah it was a total it was just well he
is completely out of line 100 percent
out of line but he's also 100
mentally not there people need to talk
about if they're going to talk about
violence right and as though words are
violence they need to talk about an
issue that you know really we don't deal
with in society that women can mentally
abuse men women i don't know if you know
the single moms are more likely to be
physically abusive towards children than
single dads that's a fact women are more
likely to be physically abusive in
marital relationships and not to mention
the mental abuse is something that's
hard to quantify it's something you know
it's a variable that's sort of hard to
to actually
you know it's it's not tangible but it
is something that takes place quite a
bit and i think we've all witnessed this
happen with will smith yeah and you know
what this is a big reason so people know
this is a big reason that men don't get
help it's a big reason that men don't we
always talk about mental health issues
in the country but the truth is if will
smith would go and get help and they get
divorced guess what she's going to try
and use that against him she's going to
try and claim that he has mental
instability problems and absolve herself
of sleeping around with multiple guys
and embarrassing him on a public stage
so that is true i do have i do have
empathy for will smith the only thing i
would say that chris rock did wrong is
you never let someone like that get that
close you get your hands out you you've
got to make sure that's my rule arm's
length arm's length i don't know you i
think though that he didn't expect that
i mean you're talking about an award
show he's coming out and he probably
thought he was going to hug him
like there's really no in there's no way
he thought you know what you do happen
you know what you do is you reach out to
hug first or you reach out to shake
hands first that gives you and we'll
talk about this tomorrow with the change
my mind that went up yesterday that's
why the very first thing i did was tell
a joke to see okay how hostile is this
guy coming in yeah put my hand out felt
his jacket like hey i like your j that's
me making sure if a slap is coming
around my my hand is here with this i'm
always aware you have to be aware if
someone is coming in into your space
coming into your space aggressively
you have to make sure
that you establish contact first and
don't ever just stand there with your
hands behind your back of course chris
rock i'm not blaming chris rock at all
i'm just saying it's a lesson for
everybody especially in today today's
day and age
people justify violence because of jokes
they don't like yeah it's tough to say
his facial expression in that moment you
know it's just it's one of those things
that it's such it's obviously such a
rare occurrence that it's happened once
at an award show right like this this
didn't even happen at the you know award
shows back in the day with the source
awards where people were actually
getting killed well yeah we thought it
was going to happen that one can we just
move the oscars to bet and get it over
with yeah we should well i mean look
this is the first time the oscars just
call it medea hands a statue yeah well
i mean everybody thought they were like
oh was this staged because the oscars
obviously the numbers are cratering
year-round we stopped doing the oscars
stream because they they were cut in
half every year which got incredible as
of sunday yeah
the one time we could have been there
when that happened right one time but it
was awesome
if she had just laughed it off like most
people tend to do in those situations
will smith never would have got up from
the table he would have kept laughing
well here's the problem we'll go through
a couple of clips here we have jim
carrey we also have a tick tock video
from the uh you know the black activist
left and how
violence has been justified in
retaliation to words for a long time now
what they've tried to say is chris rock
crossed a line because uh jada pinkett
smith has alopecia first off if you
check it's it's very mild if she does
it's a style thing people are shaving
their heads it's a style thing and
it's not a disability people say this is
ableism well because you have a bald
patch
you have a bald patch that's now what
you qualify for disability i have
titanium rods through my chest i didn't
take disability for crying out name your
kid alopecia than have a problem with it
exactly nor syphilis
i knew a wonderful gonorrhea yes
swell lady that's what they say is he
has no sympathy for that it's like
really he made a documentary called good
hair about raising his daughters in a
world where black air is kind of
unacceptable right clearly he has
sympathy and understanding and empathy
for it and he probably didn't even write
the joke so he was slapped because of
someone else's joke exactly it's it's
right they have writers he's just
raiding a prompter right no don't worry
chris rock actually did go backstage
there's a good chance that the person
who wrote that joke was banging jada
pinkett yeah
he probably wrote it in and was like
yeah
i know her
intimately now uh here's the thing so
they want to justify oh okay you're
joking about baldness and now that's a
disability well interesting that people
should bring that up because we have
this clip on arsenio hall the arsenio
hall show with will smith from uh well
some years ago that in this world man
you can't do that in this world man
arsenal they got rules they got rules
like he has a rule the base player he
got a rule he got to wax his head every
[Applause]
man she morning the rules oh these are
jokes come on
see you got too into the characters and
got hurt
someone has slapped him that's a joke
come on still better than anything on
late night now yep that's absolutely
true
there were no dancing vaccines nope oh
thank god
it's a joke man hey come on bring in the
pfizer man it's just long for the days
of yo mama jokes yeah national
television yeah when you long for the
days of the wilmer valverama show on mtv
yo mama yes yeah like that would be
better
right well i know a lot of people bring
it up to 2016 uh stuff with chris rock
going after jada pickensmith and they
were funny jokes because she was
boycotting the oscars because will smith
wasn't nominated for concussion and
saying like oh it's like you weren't
invited to ironically he gave chris rock
one well yes that's sure not really
chris took a good one he took it that
way he's a great champion right he kept
going but they were saying like oh this
is just character that was it was almost
six six years ago you're a great joke so
he's like it's it isn't fair that she
didn't get a get a nomination but it's
also not fair that you got 20 million
dollars for wild wild west and he's
right and it's a funny joke it's funny
anybody who's made a bad movie has
acknowledged it yes like that's part of
it like you have to acknowledge and i
understand that now it's social media
and there's a different world where
you're constantly being attacked every
second of every day so i understand how
that can wear on you so it's a little
bit different now than the days before
but really with this it's like you're
going after somebody who deals with the
same stuff that you do on a daily basis
yeah i think you're i think you're right
the most interesting uh dynamic here to
me is this fallout of the left running
around like chickens with their heads
cut off because they before this have
deemed this kind of behavior acceptable
and i'm going to lay out the case for
you here because i've had to deal with
this quite a bit
they've made the argument that words are
violence they've made the argument that
no words are violence silence is
violence so when you say words are
violence or silence is violence well
guess what legally you are allowed to
respond to violence in self-defense with
violence in kind that's the law
but now if you reword it that silence or
words are violence you end up with these
kinds of scenarios now it hasn't
happened at the oscars
but it's happened across our country so
now it only affects the elite guess what
this kind of behavior has been affecting
many of you for a very long amount of
time business owners black lives matter
riots
your apartments chas
your precincts
your cities homeless epidemics where
people are being attacked being raped in
record cologne germany raped in record
numbers this is the thing right you say
things that they don't like they can
respond in kind with violence and then
the left ultimately coddles them
protects them and says well that wasn't
really that wasn't really right but you
shouldn't have said that remember when
that transgender threw a lunch box at me
when i was doing it changed my mind at
the women's march he said well you know
you knew that you were trying to trigger
that person it could not be less
relevant this is how they have been
behaving for a very long time and now
the mob is coming for them and now there
are unfortunately some comedians who are
in the mob but before we get to that
there was one person and this is a
perfect example i agree with jim carrey
here i think this is the most lucid jim
carrey has been in uh probably
ever
i first heard jim carrey commented on it
i was like great then i was like really
you're on the right side of this and you
actually were able to speak wow that's
insane i thought you were going to talk
about mercury and vaccines and stuff
it's going to be another dehumanizing
painting yes exactly so here's a ventura
himself where he responded and actually
called this reporter
on something that she said i think
rightfully so effectively and what this
reporter is saying is also echoing what
you're seeing across liberal tick tock
and twitter and i'll show you that clip
after but first jim carrey what did you
think as you watched it unfold and then
what happened after
i was sickened i was sickened by the
standing ovation
i felt like hollywood is just spineless
on mass
and uh it just
it really felt like oh this is a really
clear indication that uh we're not the
cool club anymore if you want to yell
from the audience and disapprove or show
a disapproval or say something on
twitter or whatever you you know you do
not have the right to to walk up on
stage and smack somebody in the face
because they said words
no no i agree i think we all agree on
that i just thought jim that it
escalated to that you know what i mean
that it escalated to that level it
didn't escalate
came out of nowhere because will has
something going on inside him that's
frustrated and i i wish him the best i
really do i don't i don't
you know i don't have anything against
will smith he's done great things
but that was not a good moment i don't i
wouldn't say that i wish will smith the
best
i don't wish i'm the worst but the best
is a little bit of a strong word now
here's what's funny about that two
things where he says well you can't
respond to words with violence here's a
tweet from uh jim carrey supporting
black lives matter after the minneapolis
riots you know we have two billion
dollars in damages from those protests
and this tweet was in response to the
mayor posting a black lives matter mural
again
think about that there's not a
condemnation of violence there it's
black lives matter and a fist they just
burned down cities
now you're mad about a slap
americans have had to deal
with violence in response to opinions
for the last three years
of their lives you had to deal with it
for one night one person had to deal
with it for one night and now you're
dumbfounded and what i do agree with him
though i thought it was really important
and poignant that he called her on it
when she said well it escalated no no
escalation right escalation think about
it you're talking about steps it has to
escalate exactly it doesn't go from i
was laughing to the most psychotic
breakdown possible exactly in a matter
of a second that's not escalation no
that's that's an explosion yes yeah and
look all we're asking for is consistency
we would love for jim carrey to hold
that opinion across the board and say
look if you still want to support black
lives matter you have to separate
yourself from everything that they're
doing and go i believe that black
people's lives matter but i don't like
that organization because they're
burning down cities and they're violent
right that's what you have to do well
and he's right though that hollywood's
become they're not the cool kids anymore
and it's a result of the fact of what
americans have been dealing with for the
last couple years but that also tells
you what he thinks he thought that they
were the cool kids also to to that point
we just got this uh sent to us by the
edit bay the oscars were sponsored by
biontech and pfizer wow wonderful good
yeah oh that is this oh so this is the
whole point i hate everything chris rock
wasn't boosted and that's what actually
said what happened yeah that's what
happened he's going to be in he's going
to be in the hospital concussion and
i'll say covid related injuries i'm
sorry i had the johnson and johnson
that's why i did it get the get the
pfizer i screwed up i got the
astrazeneca
well smith just slapped the [ __ ] out of
she just slapped the booster out of me
tear the coven
for crying out loud i love he i'm sorry
i still find it hilarious that he won
the oscar hey don't you remember it's so
funny to me like you know he would have
done that if he was like i actually got
it i will smith i never thought i'd get
it it's like spikey getting up and
walking out he's like oh you actually i
won yeah like on the way out he's like
wait best director oh really i think
i'll come back
i do believe i can park i was crying
laughing regardless of how ridiculous
his speech was when he thanked you know
yeah level eight python or whatever yes
exactly is god he came out with his
thetan testing cane yeah oh i'm in a
good spot right now yeah
my hand hurts but
now here's the thing apparently and this
is from the left
uh there were multiple acts of violence
again this is the point of view of the
left you see it from jim carrey
supporting black lives matter supporting
antifa right they're saying that
right-wing extremists are a problem
anthony's not a terrorist organization
you can go back to my change my minds
where i said black lives matter and
antifa are domestic terror organizations
i walk that back absolutely zero these
same celebrities supported them and you
can see where they are getting these
just like you can see where they're
getting the talking points on the
vaccines if they're sponsored by them
yeah right they're beholden to these
organizations they're beholden to these
leftist ideology uh the ideological
groups they have to you see it with
disney with the the florida don't it's
not don't say gay it's don't teach kids
about sex change operations bill maybe
we can i don't know if you can fit that
in a bumper sticker yeah but here you
see from a leftist activist
echoing what was supported by people
like jim carrey and people in hollywood
saying that they were actually that
night chris rock and will smith
three acts of violence
so we witnessed three acts of violence
at the oscars last night the first was
from chris rock who invited an entire
predominantly white international
audience to laugh at jada pinkett's
which isn't whiter ability now
oftentimes comedians people use black
women making fun of black women
humiliating black women as a way to
build their own social capital it's a
way to he's a black
act of anti-blackness but it seems like
it's the way you're using black women to
get capital you're predominantly white
male audience base the second act of
violence it's your roller blade gloves
everyone went along with it that was the
performance including will smith that i
would be responding to but then because
i would have made this video regardless
but then will smith got up on the stage
and did the third act of violence which
was smacking chris rock in the face and
it's interesting the only act of
violence
what acts of violence get condemned why
officers of the state are being invited
to get involved for some reason why some
people want some people to be
criminalized because one's a felony
you're crazy [ __ ]
that's violence yeah even that's
violence it's it's there are three acts
of violence the final act of violence
and it's interesting which one people
are condemning because since the
beginning of time people say things that
you don't like and you use your words
you don't get to hit comedians for
making jokes this is what the left does
just like with black lives matter they
equivocate it's well you know what these
people are mad rioting is the language
of the unheard hey silence is violence
we see this here there were three acts
of violence one was making fun of a
black woman that's an act of violence
apparently don't know if she would feel
the same way and making fun of i don't
know white male the other is the
audience laughing the audience laughing
is an act of violence
violence is a proactive action
laughter is an involuntary reaction
correct that by the way doesn't
necessitate physical contact with
someone else's face
but if your reaction is laughter that
means you're just part of the violent
culture right yes i almost think the
prime m primarily the people responsible
for the violent culture are the people
uh hitting other people that's true
well by the definition of violence yes
and let me be clear to i also understand
and this is my question of the day what
would you consider you know them's
fighting words there are fighting words
now if yeah outside of an award show on
the street
yes there are if chris rock walked up to
jada picket jada pinkett right next to
will smith and say like you gotta find
ass
now black man and your husband's a smack
that would make sense or if he said it
at the after party right and it's rude
but when your job is to make fun of the
stars that are eating oscar-shaped
salmon then no that's not the time you
hit somebody it's that simple fact check
it was tilapia admonish
tilapia
i think it was salmon it's a light it's
a lighter it's a lighter flakier fish
salmon i think it was salmon it's a
white fish i'm not gonna apologize till
we look this up
are you gonna slap the salmon day i
wanted i wanted to know if it was
well split the difference call it smoked
salmon fine smoked salmon
it was bagels
did they have toast points gotta have
toast points what are toast points
that's can you admonish for being him
what is that what yes
what are toast points oh geez what are
those points you're digging it deeper
what are toast points the little the
crackers and stuff that you put the
salmon on as the appetizer come on
we just
did you know that they were called toast
points no no okay they they don't call
them crackers though i am the wine i
call them crackers yeah but that's an
act of violence right cracker careful
i'm not beyond smacking the two of you
right in the mouth i'm gonna walk over
there but here's the thing what re well
not here's the thing here's something
else that really bothers me uh and dave
i'm sure you have strong opinions on
this we've talked about comedians who of
course have supported the idea i hate to
use the word cancel culture but have
supported the uh cultural censorship of
other comedians no comedians coming out
against louis ck just for just for doing
comedy again with willing audiences
comedians coming out against other
comedians who said joke that they find
offensive and so they try and get them
canceled they try and get them banned
this is something that i've had to deal
with for a very long time and now you
see comedians and i'm in comedians who
are on comedy central comedians who are
actual professional working comedians
supporting acts of violence
being committed against comedians so
here's a transgender comedian robin tran
was positively giddy about it
and tweeted can someone do that ricky
gervais next it doesn't even have to be
an awards show
look do you know that that could be you
next that's the thing you've just
declared open season on yourself and
here's the we i've had to deal with this
for a long time dave you've talked about
has kind of been a rude awakening for
you sometimes and that when we do shows
together look i i was i stopped doing
stand-up for a period of time and for
the same reason we had to stop doing
change my minds you saw what happened
recently we had someone throw a
milkshake we had someone try to tackle
me we had someone pick up a rock which
they then claimed was well we're just
using it to kneel on to take a picture i
don't know why i need a rock to take a
picture i've taken plenty of pictures in
my life i never once i never once needed
a kneeling rock
but
i wasn't able to do stand-up and live
appearances because i was at a point in
my life where i was
famous enough to have a big crowd but
not not wealthy enough to have the
resources to hire the security and now i
am able to do that so i've been back on
the road with dave by the way you can go
to light of credit.com tour we are in
tulsa oklahoma may 14th the tulsa
ballroom and uh colorado springs june
18th just go to the website there are
tickets there available but dave you've
seen how different it is even with our
show the kind of security that we have
to have
that people have to run interference
yeah i mean they it definitely is a
little bit different and it's it's
because of the world we're living in
right now it's because people have to be
wanted they have to be kind of searched
looked over it's it's a it's a shame
yeah it honestly is a shame and it's
because there are comics going against
comics that's one of the crappy parts
like what you just showed ricky gervais
did nothing except call out the
hypocrisy of hollywood and pedophilia he
did yes yeah yeah yeah yeah he called
out focus on pedophilia he's your friend
is one of the funniest things i've ever
heard come out of somebody's mouth it
was hysterical another funny one he said
uh this next presenter is ashton
kutcher's dad bruce willis everybody yes
and i well and it was also
everything that he said was funny and on
point and good and that's exactly what
an award show should be and it crossed
the line a little bit because comedy
should cross the line a little bit yes
it should be uh discomfort it should be
but it also should be a relief from
society right from dealing with
everybody's take myself so seriously
[ __ ] pardon my language but that's
the reality is we all take ourselves way
too seriously now yeah we we have this
this ability to just
completely go with comedians because we
don't like what they said
same like you said louis ck there's a
reason why he's selling out 5 000 seat
venues all over the world right it's
because people crave that people want
that they don't want to just keep
shaming everybody because they say
something they disagree with right or
masturbate in a green room well yeah but
he had permission he had permission all
they wanted it's a little weird but it
was it was consensual yeah he had
willing audiences he's had willing
audiences exactly i've performed to two
people before yes
hey quick trust me i would have rather
been mad it's because you're wet that's
because your chat room is just very
empty yeah it really is come on guys
quick fun fact check stephen you were
right and 20 20 wolfgang puck served
smoked salmon
no that's dave was right but you said
smoke i said smoked ah this but i was
right about the fish salmon don't you
just give him that that's a point you
know what let's see
let's split the difference
let's split the difference no one needs
to be slapped here
can you show a picture of that though
again to highlight our point yes show
that if you're eating this you can't be
upset
about anything
the only thing you could be upset about
is maybe your wife banging a bunch of
rappers yeah
that night yeah the fact that your wife
comes out with a post malone shaped
imprint yes
it says cry whatever
his hand tier tattoo rubs off are those
capers for the buttons is that what that
is uh i don't think so what are the
bumps on a pretentious log there's no
toast points that's like pesto
smoked salmon on crackers and pesto i
get it that you're human too but you're
at a trophy show for pretending you're
someone else yes exactly yeah that's
that's not but the issue here is that
this is just coming for them and i've
had arguments with comedians on this
show comedians on the show who would say
you know no it's not going to happen
with comedy and i would say look it's
happening to me they'd be like well
you're you know you're doing your thing
and it's not necessarily uh the same
thing but no the reason i have to change
what i do and can't just do stand-up
comedy for a certain period in my life
is because this is what is happening and
it's going to come for you next i cannot
tell you how many comedians said i don't
think that's coming for comedy and now
not only is it coming for comedy you
have you have comedians who have joined
the pitchfork mob and guess what as for
me and my house we are not going to bow
to that come out enjoy the shows dave it
is rough i warn you it is not just this
show it can get rough and if you're
easily offended you should just stay
home you shouldn't show up yeah if
you're easily offended and you already
booked the ticket
refund it there you go not because it's
graphic it's not just because it's
comedy yeah right well so here i have a
question not dirty it's just i'm just
telling you it's just not uh it's it's
rough yeah i had i had a bit of a
reaction to somebody on twitter and i
saw this in a
they can say whatever they want i get it
but that can't be something you hide
behind as a comedian if you go after
somebody you know that you can you are
uniquely skilled to piss them off in a
way that maybe other people can't that's
great right we and i know but you
understand pretty funny there can be a
line you said it earlier right so as a
comedian people were hiding behind that
i'm like look i don't support going up
and hitting somebody for what they say
to you either way but comedians can't
then go well i'm a comedian i'm just
doing what i'm dropping my job of course
i'm talking about outside of that
setting no i'm talking about outside of
that setting but on stage i can make fun
of anyone any way that i want
100 yes and no
if it's done in the guise of a joke
that's actually funny and you're not
just being a a dick i absolutely but
where's the line between being a dick
and saying something that's funny
because sometimes you don't have to you
don't have to think it's funny you just
have to acknowledge that it's a joke
let's say he had attacked will smith's
wife who's not a celebrity
i would have considered that crosstalk
what if he what if he had said this what
if he said ha ha is as dry as your womb
that that salmon i've made that joke
yeah it'd be funny i made that [ __ ]
carly fiorina's barren womb i would have
left three times harder yes and she's
somebody who can't have children
yeah yeah i'd laugh i i don't think so
i'm sorry you can listen if it's if
you're a comedian and you can't comedian
you can say that but i have every right
to kick your ass after the show for
saying something like you don't you
don't though why does being a comedian
give you the license to say whatever you
want without people why would you give a
rapper the license to to talk about
burying pete davidson barry and pete
davidson
because because they're just not talking
figuratively i'm talking literally barry
and pete davidson ah he would actually
the gesture was an untouchable part of
society that brought light to everybody
and pointed out that i get it think
about marilyn manson think about rap
think and for some reason people want to
hold comedians to this standard as
though it's reality i don't know about
you dave sometimes i tell stories on
stage that aren't true
yeah or partially true or partial
because embellishment is the essence of
storytelling exactly i agree you need a
wide berth for sure and i and we have
actually stood up for jada pink and
smith i just
come out for me first you can fit
tugboats in there
for me to even answer your question
though i don't go up on stage and trash
other people like my entire act is about
me neither one of you guys yeah so it's
like i really can't tell you like why
but what he did and even i've never seen
it i've never seen a comic go up on
stage and say anything to an audience
that is uh worthy of getting hit never i
don't think i have either i was just it
pissed me off that somebody said it the
way that they did i'm like listen i
support you almost like i support free
speech but don't think because you're a
comedian that you can say whatever to
whoever whenever you want
whatever to who look when you were if
you're on the street or in conversation
with someone you're not being a comedian
at that point you're having a
conversation with a human being that's
very different right on stage as a
comedian when you're performing you need
yep sorry you don't get to hit somebody
that's just how it works
it used to be you paid money to for this
ticket so you had a certain sense of
freedom and there's also this certain
sense of danger there if you're like in
the front or whatever of course you need
you know there's a part of it there's a
rush and it goes for both the performer
and the audience where there's this
agreement that this is allowed if you if
you feel that way go sit front row at a
damorera show right okay like yeah
you'll find out really quickly that uh
you're like hey you can't say that then
they were like oh this guy says i can't
say that this dumb son of a [ __ ] who's
right whose gut walked in four minutes
before he did who's hit and he'll just
go on and on
i got i get picked on at the laugh
factory when i was on a visit to ucla
right felicio i no it was funny but i
was just like oh i just was sitting here
like i was i wasn't familiar with comedy
at all there was like hey we're going to
a comedy club which i don't even do that
but they have the right to well yeah but
for my generation you had chris rock
being and chris rock and dave chappelle
for example uh they were the
the voice of my generation when i was in
college i mean they were where i was
there for a year but when i was the age
i should have been in college the
college age but i opened for chappelle
to 7 000 people i mean he stepped away
from it like he's a guy who
he made fun of everything and himself in
his act and then on his show you know it
was the voice of my generation
will smith
he was hancock i felt get hancock yeah i
felt like i was getting i'm just
referring to what's in his hand right
now
by the way not wills no no no he's he's
on a rotation he's totally straight um
it's just his show is nobody bangs will
all right now uh let's move on to uh oh
i don't know if this is something else
before we get to the don't say gay bill
which is not a bill and don't say gay
doesn't appear there anywhere and ron
perlman is the ugliest human being who's
ever listen ron perlman every single
thing about you is ugly okay you're a
snow gorilla before we move on from that
they just do they just duplicated him in
congo
give ron prominent laser gun that'll be
that'll be the climax there you go so
you know uh klaus schwab yeah yeah
schwab he's the german leader of the
world economic forum and architect of
the great reset uh today is his birthday
oh yeah today is his birthday really old
speaking of countries in uh in in uh in
western europe have you have you ever
been to austria dave no not yet but i am
planning to well if you do you know what
this is what we have for uh in honor of
mr schwab today uh the top six things to
do while you're in vienna
[Music]
top six things to do that's i don't know
we picked that number uh when you're in
vienna austria
uh
number one
well there are there are flowers you can
smell you can smell the smell flowers in
vienna i don't know my allergies are
pretty bad i'm not very interested in
hold hours sniffing i'm confused why in
the world are we talking about vienna
and flowers well actually that's just
because we needed a segue related to
austria uh and uh nasal issues so this
is why
you know doc i just i haven't been able
to stop smoking
this is called oral fixation
your mother never breastfed you enough
i think i just like the nicotine buzz
and i also haven't been sleeping very
well
nine
it's definitely is a bitty and
your mother never did you sleep in her
bed we were really poor so i had to
share a bed with my parents and my four
siblings so you never quite had your
mother all to yourself
anyway i had an intense fear of spiders
that's because your mom clearly never
tied you up in a giant web and poured
hot candle wax on you with all due
respect i don't really feel like i'm
being heard i've been coming here for
six months and all you want to do is
talk about my mother okay fine you want
to know about my mother her favorite
show is walker texas ranger
she has crippling arthritis and her
arthritis medication gives her ibs which
is great on top of that she looks
exactly like mama for telly from the
freaking goonies
here doc
why don't you take this
so yeah that's this it's a drug-free
nasal spray that used to clean out your
nasal passages from things like pollen
dander and even harmful bacteria it uses
the natural power of xylitol xylitol
i've heard of this this is a
hallucinogenic yes uh no it's drug free
drug free that means no drugs no no
drugs there's no drugs
because that's
fun too
oh thank you that is that's much better
sure now
we were talking about
your mother
is she hot
[Music]
go wash your nose you filthy cretans
it's uh clear spelled with an x uh
they're actually sponsored the show they
only became a sponsor when i was talking
about using their product uh you know
okay this is anecdotal before well first
of all okay it uses xylitol which is a
natural thing you know and like the
chewing gum that you use it's
anti-cavity it's doctor recommended it
can actually clear out your nasal
passages you think of you washing your
face and brushing your teeth you can get
an amazon pharmacies you can go to their
website to see all the published
clinical data when i had the covid it
was very mild and i used this to clean
out my nose tested negative kept testing
negative even though i had so then i i
stopped using it for about it required
about 12 hours and then you're like oh
you have covet i was like oh okay well
this cleared it all out well i guess so
you mean when they put the swab into
your brain to see if you actually had
coveted yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay it
tickled my brain tickle the cortex i
smelled burnt toast or what are they
called toasties taste pennies toast
points toast points damn you all toast
points toast points
somebody back what an affected prick
so
no no look no seriously i get it like he
likes the toast because you know he runs
a wine business simplified wine.com he's
a sommelier and he eats toast points and
you know it's a delicious food i would
never eat toast once because i'm not
that big of a prick but that's something
that he really is into what would you
recommend to uh uh somebody eating
smoked salmons
smoked salmon there you go right there
would you recommend with with that a new
smoked salmon and aioli and toast points
and maybe a nice chianti would it be
chianti for real no not at all but what
would you have with it white wine yeah
what's your favorite sauvignon blanc
would be great i would recommend eating
the rich this is the only instance where
i would recommend it isn't that a 13
year old child actress
i don't know well roman roman polanski
was a big fan
smash the like button if you're watching
on youtube because guess what that helps
the algorithm smash the like button
leave a comment below we're about to
discuss
there's a final smash we're about to
discuss the um
florida bill the freak out over this
florida bill they try to say the don't
say gay bill and this is wonderful this
is what the left does is they we saw
this with the change my minds that went
up yesterday they misrepresent
your position
and then they this is what we call straw
manning right and then they destroy that
position that you've never actually held
so they misrepresent the bill calling it
the don't say gay bill they did this
with the star wars missile defense
system and ronald reagan that's how
other people named it to try and mock
him
so they said they don't say gay bill and
then they start protesting i can't
believe you would have a don't say gay
billy there's nothing says don't say gay
in that bill well that's what i heard
yes because you're on ron perlman's
twitter
yeah that's so true and i'm not a source
i'm the affected prick
come on no no no that'll be them no yes
of course they're just girls
i mean you're arrogant
with
[Applause]
you should see his son his son is not
only blonde hair blue eyed he's the
largest baby i have ever yeah but his
kid can get down to some sweet music yes
kid loves hip-hop it's hilarious he was
dancing together
you have to admit it i saved your son's
life that one time you did he almost
fell three inches because you had gerald
had an entirely appropriate baby seat
yes for his age but he's like two times
the size yeah and so we're going to be
getting dinner and he was on a ledge
probably about as high as this table and
he just did this he didn't even do a
full kip he just did this with his leg
like he was stepping over you know like
a slightly tall fence yes and he started
falling
and i gave him to gerald's wife
every dad has that moment where you turn
around to grab the fresh diaper and you
just hear
and you're like oh like when you die in
donkey kong country and the balloon pops
yeah you're like oh dear
table should
i don't ever have to talk about this
happening
also when the kid just starts walking
and
rocking and walking on his toes oh
boy
now i'm gonna have an i am sam kid there
goes that scholarship first so
let me just don't say gay bill
misrepresenting it doesn't say don't say
gay in the bill it's about not
sexualizing education for kids however
the left has repeatedly
deliberately inaccurately
represented it and and here you go
here's just a don't take my word for it
and for you people in florida we're
going to have a gay night
the original meaning wow amy schumer
turns sideways and it's the same as when
she's standing front ways
there shot a will smith before the slap
and denzel before he said the devils
are yeah protesting that don't say
gabriel i wanted to give you an
opportunity to comment on that effort oh
just my comment would be gay gay gay gay
gay gay
gay gay gay gay gay gay
good morning governor desantis
wrong here
we knew ron um yeah thanks
don't say gay
don't say
as the first two words
in a sentence spoken by a political
leader
don't say what do you care you're from
the congo don't [ __ ] say you [ __ ]
nazi pig
say
first amendment
read about it
then run for office
you piece of [ __ ]
okay so first off he's already in office
second it's not a sentence that he's
uttered third when you're that ugly just
back up just back the camera up a little
bit use a marilyn monroe lens filter for
like recognize that it's a very very
off-putting face and i realize that's ad
hominem and i'm okay with it he does
look like the white apes from congo he
looks actually a little worse now yes he
does he doesn't have to announce his
name either there's not another human on
the planet that looks like that right
looks like the hey it's me ron yeah we
know ryan it looks like he should be on
his deathbed signing that he's
like i see the white light yes
when he dies they should like take half
his face and just use it for the phantom
of the opera play just it should and
they take off the mask
they see my pearlman
play the organ he said videos
he's a hideous man who what do they need
for hellboy paint yeah that's it that's
it we need to make you look like a demon
child all right well we have a little
bit of blush and uh we're good ah done
you already had five minutes
are you sure that's all we need for
makeup you nazi prick you not so per se
by the way watch my show that for eight
seasons advocates nazi pricks yes
exactly
and violence non-stop endlessly which by
the way he also advocates uh against
people he doesn't like so he doesn't
really have a very firm understanding of
the first amendment but before we allow
you to say don't say gay and you to be
against it right exactly
he doesn't understand and he always
tries to play tough guy because you know
he has the head the size of a coke
machine but then he has arms that look
like buggy whips so it's just one of
those things
yeah the phone's actually 30 feet away
and someone else is filming right
like this is the best i can do with the
frame run yeah i can't get out of the
room and film something with the scale
and the depth of still cutting off a
little bit of your chin but i can't i
can't go any farther i'll fall
it's a big chin ron okay that's what i'm
saying i can't do anything for crying
out loud get some lightning strips yeah
could your wife just pull some more bugs
out of your hair and eat them yes
oh he's gonna go on a bath salt bender
because of red wine and xanax and his
handler you know what get the change my
mind uh get to change my mind monkey
handler and have him you know have him
take care of ron seems like he's in a
tough spot his banana cake birthday yes
so it has nothing to do with the first
amendment this bill okay uh let's just
be really clear about this oh do i have
a tweet from ron perlman okay let me
just show you too ron prominent he
doesn't give a crap about the first man
here's uh we finally found it a
disturbingly large and unfathomably
stupid swath of the american public is
being incited into believing lies by one
single individual if this individual
isn't brought to justice for the damage
death and violence he has caused i will
be the fir among the first to take to
the streets i would love to see ron
perlman take it to the streets
uh how how many times
does the bill uh
well first of all before i
weren't they already in the streets when
he tweeted that yes exactly
i think i think that's true i will be
the second
140th
in the streets yeah i will i'm only
tweeting this because of the news about
the violence in the streets but i will
be the first to be there yes ah yes
thank you i don't know how anything
works especially time yes
i can't open jars and how many times how
many times does the bill actually say
gay by the way zero that would be zero
ah so uh two days ago governor ron
desantis signed the parental rights and
education bill which what is it look it
bains we've done a whole segment on this
ban sexual indoctrination uh grades k
through three yes that's kindergarten
yeah five through eight-year-olds just
so
let me read and all references are
available the link is in the description
or the pinned comment or lido's
credit.com if you just want to go there
uh classroom instruction by school
personnel or third parties on sexual
orientation or gender identity may not
occur in kindergarten through grade
three or in a manner that is not
appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students in according
with state standards
so reasonable totally reasonable now
this is where they say you're conserving
conservatives are just obsessed with the
idea of sexualizing children and
pedophilia it's the q anon thing no no
first off cuenon people are morons i've
always said that you've heard me do
these segments on the show that being
said the left is absolutely absolutely
obsessed with sexualizing children i
present to you uh
cuties now florida uh is of course a
place where it's a bastion of insanity
and this one florida teacher is
distraught because he can no longer talk
about with children have you seen this
with children his weekend escapades
it scares me
to death that i am not going to be able
to have these conversations with my
children because they're going to ask me
what i did on the weekend i don't want
to have to hide that my partner and i
went paddleboarding this weekend because
then they asked what his partner he was
doing paddled on a board no i'm worried
can i tell them what it means i'm also
worried for my kids i have a little girl
this year who has two moms and the kids
are curious about her two moms they want
to know about her two moms you know if
they come to if they go to her and ask
her about her two moms and she doesn't
know what to say they're going to come
to me and ask me and then you know so
what do i tell them about the public
stall from the los angeles county
parents to really take some legal action
against the schools and teachers and i
am afraid for myself my colleagues and
my students this is see this same kind
of language
this is what leads to violence i am
afraid you're afraid because you can't
teach kindergartners about your weekend
swingers parties you're afraid because
you can't teach kids in the first grade
of all your queer party friends by the
way he can answer the question hey mr
corey what'd you do this weekend i went
paddle boarding yes done yeah
they just lie and say you know kayaking
so they'll think you're by yourself well
that's how anybody else would answer the
question yeah i don't know or you could
just say why does she have two mommies
oh
because she has two mommies and the
six-year-old's gonna go okay or you
could just say here's a cupcake and
they'll forget all about it right that's
true you're gonna time out it does it
mean did i say cupcake i meant puberty
blockers nobody's saying you can't tell
them that yeah no i know you can't have
inappropriate comments you just can't
teach kids about it because follow that
logic through if we start down that road
as a five or six year olds do you think
they're going to be satisfied at some
point they're going to be like well wait
i have a mommy and a daddy why like the
next day why do you have two mommies
just answer it answer it without texting
like my junior high french teacher and i
said hey mr alone what'd you do this
weekend he said mind your own business
okay good enough for me do you think uh
in the next room the teacher is like
yeah my wife sucked it for a while yeah
how you kids doing this is totally
illegal boy i did some stuff with my
wife this weekend in an order that would
surprise you it was my birthday so anal
any other questions
and by that i mean i got the overly
persnickety about the cake i'm picky i
got anal about the cake now disney of
course has been vocal in its opposition
nobody's bringing up sex i know it's
absolutely it's a fair point yes you
don't need to bring up sex with kids how
about that also hey hollywood i'm
looking at you stop having sex with
actual kids so disney has been vocal in
his opposition hollywood's all like no
no
you're not the boss of me
and unsurprisingly um they've been uh
actively injecting now don't take my
word for it actively inserting this is
disney pixar queerness into children's
programming here you go our leadership
over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda all that like momentum
that i felt like that
sense of i don't have to be afraid to
like
let's have these two characters kiss
let's in the background like i was just
wherever i could just basically adding
queerness to like if you see anything
queer in the show
but like i just was like no one would
stop me and no one was trying to stop
somebody should have stopped you boy
this should unfreeze walt disney yeah
i'm sure he would be thrilled oh yeah
unfreeze him with his nazi memorabilia
right like i shot her that's still legal
right yes yes yes yes of course i'm
gonna draw mickey and her blood yeah
so this chris rock fellow was a woman
that uh will smith slapped right but
yeah
totally legal in my time i don't
understand the rules but governor
desantis i'm a big fan of this guy
responded to the comments uh at uh at
one of these uh i guess the same meeting
why is the hill to die on to have
transgenderism injected into
kindergarten classrooms or woke gender
ideology injected into second grade
classroom why is that the hill to die on
meanwhile if we had done a bill that
prohibited kill that teacher was
screwing out on the weekend abuse
disney would have supported that
legislation because they didn't want to
say a word about that experience so it's
just an odd manifestation of their
corporate values that they actually do
disney cruises tucker to the nation of
dominica which criminalizes
homosexuality so they're fine doing that
and lining their pockets they're fine
lining their pockets from the ccp and
all the atrocities that go on there but
it's those kindergartners in florida
that they really want to have
transgenderism
as part of their core curriculum in
school that's a good point hey disney
how about you worry about the
kindergartners making shoes in the
market you're breaking into
how about that disney cruising is one of
my favorite movies yes yes disney
cruising for a bruising
don't you just love that that's how
they've run out of ideas or something
like we need a new disney film i don't
know uh we did the pirates of the
caribbean that was a ride how about
jungle cruise
good
good what what's it going to be about
well well this will put they'll be
cruising um
in the jungle we'll have a few we'll
have a few swinging ron perlmans that'll
be a nice call back to congo i think
everyone will be happy about it yeah
great brilliant
nostalgia cells are we good really
jumanji we're going to make three of
them yes a video game yeah
and we're going to remake it and they
sat there and they pitched jumanji they
said okay look look look all right
picture this
okay
pictured you everyone loved picture
jumanji remember jumanji
only
lesser
um
someone get kevin hart on the phone all
right we actually have our guests coming
up and i want to ask him about a few of
these things and also uh with
ben shapiro presented him some stand-up
that i've done where i you know poke a
little bit of fun at ben and see if he
wants to slap me because you know he has
connections he should with the jewish
mafia where he could just send them out
to slap me so it's time for our guest
you know him you love him let's bring
let's bring out ben shapiro
[Music]
mr shapiro host of the ben shapiro show
there at daley wire how are you sir
i'm doing well how are you in the great
state of florida where things are still
free yes everyone else moved to
nashville and you moved to florida ben
why was smart now well yes was this
was this because there was more of a
community in in florida that uh or
family in florida yeah no that this is
basically if i had moved with my family
to nashville we would have doubled the
jewish population of the entire state of
tennessee
i didn't know as you know florida is is
largely jews and cubans yeah yes jewish
honky tonks yes many jewish hockey
thoughts oh man i'd go for that that
sounds amazing
gosh i do wonder i mean are there a lot
of cuban jews now then in in uh there
are a few actually there are a few yeah
wow so they are they are very buoyant
and whiny
yeah i got nothing for you imagine that
if they were already jewish cubans
leaving cuba they would be complaining
the whole trip like i'm floating on a on
a desk chair they couldn't get us a
canoe
this car door from a volkswagen
we're pretty good yes yes what they have
a there's car doors from a volkswagen
they couldn't give me a gm
nazis made these nazis made these i'll
never buy one as long as i live but
mercedes absolutely i can't drive down
rodeo in a toyota so
um
ben before i move on to
the slap that you saw at the oscars you
know we used to livestream the oscars
you guys used to we haven't done in a
couple years because it just got after
the shape of water where it was just
that you know that lady wanting to have
sex with a fish and then roma won that
year yeah i said i'm i'm done uh what's
your take on the slap with will smith
and chris first of all i think that if
we're not teaching children that people
can have sex with fish uh then i don't
know what disney's coming to these days
don't say sex with fish
don't say sex with fish sex with fish
sex
yeah i mean um yeah we we stopped paying
attention to the oscars a few years ago
when the viewership dropped below that
of the grass on your front lawn yes and
and so there was really no point in
covering it and then but listen honestly
if i've been guaranteed that every year
from here on out a celebrity was just
gonna get smacked across the face
i'm back in can we take polls on this
like can we can we vote beforehand which
celebrity just gets jacked up like i'm
i'm into this like what can we bring
back remember in football the the
broadcast used to have the jacked up and
then they got rid of it because they
decided that people didn't like violence
in football which is literally the only
reason people watch football yes uh but
what if we brought it back for the
oscars like let's just open next year's
oscars with the rock just pile driving
somebody yeah i'm in well i'm i'm all
and the problem is you're a big enough
of a celebrity ben where you might top
that list
no no no not even a question i think
it's a great idea it's like the oscars
purge edition yes we could do that
yeah chris rock's not gonna get hit if
there's a vote there you go right you
hit with salmon and maybe a statue and
then will smith gets pissed because
you're sleeping well you're not sleeping
with us next year will smith gets i mean
i mean i may be the only man in america
who's not sleeping with his wife i'm not
you guys we can either confirm nor deny
that yeah we can't confirm nor deny and
i can't confirm more than i that even
you are not ben because i've only done
finger stuff yes it's it doesn't count
if it's will smith's wife that's the
rule careful ben shapiro is a good man
and he's a good man his wife is
wonderful he broke though he would be an
ap he did break ben shapiro broke
hey ben if you could slap anyone from
history
don't say hitler okay don't don't lean
in
if you could slap anyone from history
not hitler
who would it be
well i mean
like are there ramifications afterwards
no no no no no stalin things go real
poorly right
same thing with like mal like any of the
these dictators you slap like you might
be able to get away with the slap it's
just what comes after that's bad so
we're talking about like consequence
free slap yes consequence free slap one
free slip
oh um
i mean you kind of have to go stalin
right yeah i mean i guess stalin's a
good choice if it's a celebrity who
would you slap oh celebrity um ooh um
you can say jada pinkett
all of them i know
no i can't but it has to be a white man
right because if it's if i say anything
other than a white man yeah i'm
immediately thrown in prison ronnie just
saying but that's gonna even thinking it
right now even if i even though i think
it at the moment like it might yeah
thought crime is a reality so um i'm
gonna ron perlman but you'd have to wear
like a rollerblading wrist guard
so uh all right ben look because i want
to talk to you about us
you know this this kind of culture
that's been created of open season on
comedians and talk about us uh you know
you you speak on college campus i've
obviously done stand up for a long time
and i've only recently gotten back to
doing stand-up but i don't do college
campuses anymore i've had to stop um but
in stand-up i want to see uh we're able
to watch and react here and ask ben
before so i do a little bit in stand-up
about you and i want to see if this
warrants me being slapped and i offer my
non-apologies in advance this was i
believe taped at the majestic in dallas
because i've never really felt
comfortable doing live reads in the show
it's always awkward i can't just feather
it in like been shaping well you know as
a matter of fact i think that
any parents who put their child on
puberty blockers is uh committing child
abuse and it's disgusting and almost as
disgusting as 200 count bed sheets
that's why i use bowling brand veggies
is that a commercial
if the fact what's happening at the
southern border is uh unnecessary and
why we need a wall and you two can break
down the wall of plaque on your teeth
with a quick toothbrush you're like that
little
it's a commercial
that little jude did it again
ben shapiro he doesn't age
he looks so young
kevin spacey tried to bang him he's just
[Applause]
and i've since added the cast that the
priests don't know if they're more
disappointed that you're jewish or 40.
so ben
would you hit me
you sick son of a [ __ ]
alec baldwin
first of all pretty much the i wouldn't
hit you because the first time we met
you almost choked me to death that's
true so i'm i'm going to go no it was an
accident
it was it was an accident and it was not
during any sort of um
disney approved activity no it was not
it was it was actually just you're
trying to show me how a suppression hold
worked yes and uh submission to this day
i remember how suppression hold works oh
[Music]
definitely an auspicious meeting it's
because you and i like we always rib
each and even when i mention you i
talked to the audience before you didn't
see it they always they cheer right ben
shapiro and it's poke you've poked fun
at me so many times you've used the mug
as an ashtray you know and then i tried
to use your tumbler as an ashtray but i
didn't realize of the asbestos so it lit
on fire so the point is we all have we
all have our things and i just think
that being a public figure we have to
accept and it doesn't mean that it's
mean but i mean yeah good this is yes
okay so a few things one
i've been manhandled by a
man who says a lady on national tv
and this happened in 2014 on cnn
headline news yes and the entire group
of people in the room immediately turned
and said how dare you sir say sir to
this biological man right i was the
person who was wrong so like this was of
no shock to me if you say the wrong
thing and then you are met with physical
consequences it's the same the wrong
thing that was the problem and this has
been the left's position for a very very
long time so i i was not shocked by this
in any way shape or form as far as like
public figures taking ribbing i mean
i am maybe
most famous these days for my rendition
of whap
so
yeah i've taken my my fair number of
shots and by the way there were a bunch
of
i thought rather offensive jokes told
about my wife at the time and we laughed
at most of them and even the ones we
didn't laugh at were like
you know whatever doesn't kill me makes
me more famous and rich so all right
all right
nice nice transition there i will say
this though because you know i had been
doing stand-up for a long time and i
didn't really do like the college camp
but then i was doing these college
campus sort of hybrid of stand-up and
speeches and even changed my mind you
know which i would do six years ago
maybe six seven years ago i don't know
when i started
this last one got really dicey we had a
quite a few acts of violence and we have
to have a lot of security
you remember when you were in utah and
they handed me my producer an ice pick
and someone was arrested for using the
taser that they were planning on using
on you or members of your crowd so this
has been going on for a while but i will
say it has gotten so much worse the last
two years where it's just not worth it
that's why dave and i just we book
venues where we can control everything
and just do stand-up because i don't
want to deal with it yeah we have
security because the schools never
provide the security or if they do it's
not enough have you noticed the shift
because people have talked about this
for a long time but in the last two
years how much worse it's gotten and how
much more emboldened they are as far as
violence
yeah i mean there's no question that i i
think that over the past you know two
three years you're right security's
gotten way worse and that's why i rely
on ring alarm now ring they make a
really fantastic product make sure that
my house is protected my kids are
protected at all times they've got ring
alarm pro which protects not only your
house well it also affects your see
that's how you take a joke
and by the way you get 10 off if you
enter in a promo code anti-semite sweat
dream yeah yeah
hey do we get some ring money on that
deal like it's well we should but ben's
going to keep it all he's going to put
it offshore
who are you talking to come on no
no it has though it's gotten it's gotten
really bad and
it's bad it's bad i mean like the the
you know i will say that for a couple
years it felt like it let up and then
after black lives matter in 2020 uh it
started to sort of ratchet up again i i
haven't been on as many campuses
recently mainly because
as i get older it's weirder and weirder
to go talk to college students like you
know it used to be that when i was
talking to college students 10 years ago
i was 28 and so i was talking to people
who were almost my generation now the
people i'm talking to are
closer to my kids age than they are to
my age and so i'm getting to the point
where it's like do i really want to
spend tons of time you know speaking on
college family and all that what was
that i said yeah but you could pass for
a freshman so you still have a few i
mean listen my youthful good looks
may they never leave me i said youthful
yeah yeah the idea is look 30 until
you're dead
like a german shepherd by the same time
sorry i didn't mean i didn't mean to go
german i mean it could be a golden
retriever yeah
so
wow so we are
yeah on college campuses listen i always
have a lot of security on college
campuses right it's been a little while
since we've had a real security incident
mainly because when you're doing change
my mind you're like out in a public
square right up on top of the students
yeah and and so for me i'm usually on a
stage a little bit of remove from the
students but that's because that's what
security dictates right they don't want
me going out in in crowds specifically
for this reason and somebody's going to
throw a punch uh or or somebody's going
to you know try to lever a physical
attack and despite the fact that as you
know i am a physical beast just a
monument of a specimen yes uh that that
that that's why i pay peasants to take
the physical beatings for me yes i'm not
going to i'm not going to do that myself
i mean that's that's peasant you pay the
plebs to take the beating for you no uh
we had a recently changed my mind
someone just lift up a big rock and uh
you know pops crowder who does security
he said hey hey what are you doing you
can't you go i was taking this i was
gonna take this rock and move it so i
can kneel on it for a picture and my dad
said no
no well put it turns out that it was
fezak from the princess bride
rocks for no reason um that's what i do
i don't know about you i'm just walking
around i'm like you know what i'm gonna
kneel on a rock yes exactly she's gonna
do it yeah just walking around pick up a
rock it's more comfortable to kneel on a
rock than on the soft ground um that was
also oj's excuse they found him with a
knife on him he was like you know i was
actually just kneeling on this knife
carrying around this bloody knife
i don't know why just had that urge that
day that was the same thing with rodney
king like well we just were we were
kneeling on this guy we didn't where was
i going to put my knee he was right
there no there was a rock it was just
crack yes exactly the point but they
preferred the body yes
it goes in order body
rock
soft ground now uh joe biden before we
go to mud club exclusive he made these
three massive gaffes last week and i
wanted to ask you about this you know
the regime changed the chemical weapons
the sending troops to ukraine and he was
asked about this by ducey and he said
none of those happened uh two questions
first off did it happen i think i know
the answer yes but i want to hear yours
and then at what point is this demented
old circus monkey an actual national
security risk because that is something
that's unusual okay i mean now i mean
yeah yes it happened two does he know
what happened
maybe he actually believes it didn't
happen
i mean it's it's always a good sign when
you have to send out kate bettingfield
the white house comms director to say
she literally said this in a press
conference yesterday
she had to say the sounds coming out of
the old man's face are his choice
she really said like the things he says
he's the only one deciding what he's
going to say i've never had to say that
about another human being
like ever yeah have you ever had to say
about another being you know he's saying
what he's saying because he wants to say
it you've never had to say that because
that's sort of the baseline assumption
when human beings have sounds come out
of their face yeah um and uh and yet we
have to be assured that there is not in
fact some sort of pull string on the
back of joe biden that you pull and then
those weird whispery creepy noises come
come out of him and the the crypt opens
and then he kind of yes
and the press conference ends like what
just happened i mean listen is it he's
here's the thing about that people will
say well you know trump said crazy stuff
too yeah yeah yes trump said crazy stuff
too the difference was that when trump
said crazy stuff there was no
expectation he would not say crazy stuff
right right like the expectation was
okay he's going to say some stuff as
i've said before donald trump's epitaph
it will say donald trump 45th president
of the united states said a lot of stuff
right yes i don't say stuff i see i say
another word yes yeah that that okay
fine like we all get that joe biden came
in and he was supposed to be the pro and
he's the guy who knows what he's doing
he's the adult in the room and instead
he's coming out he's like oh i might use
chemical weapons in on russia and i was
like what did you just say yeah i never
said i don't know what you're hearing
yeah hey go on i might send troops to
when you guys are in ukraine shooting
russian soldiers and everybody's like
what did you just say i didn't say
anything you hear something going on
right here
no when we you know when we decide that
we were going to uh depose vladimir
putin and what did you say no i was just
expressing thoughts that were going
between my ears and bouncing around in
there like a bird in a cage
yeah i don't know what you heard yeah
yes it's a national security threat at
this point yes now uh
well you know okay we're going to go to
muggle really quickly because i have a
couple of the questions i want to ask
you about the u pen incident of course
uh having a a daughter right this is
something that affects i think it
changes people's minds a lot of people
once you have kids uh but uh he is host
of venture the benchmare show on the
daily wire you uh what's the other best
thing to plug for you ben is it like you
have like 19 books you've been writing
since you were four
you got all of them you can follow me on
twitter if you want to see my name
thoughts of the day but yeah daily wire
or bench bureau show is gonna be the
best place yeah he also not just wep he
does a great cover of today was a good
day so uh let's go to mug club only
because youtube this could get us spicy
piss off
you